Since the birth of this great nation men and
women have fought and died,
to protect the very freedoms in which we all
have so much pride.
And as they spilled their blood at Gettysburg
saving freedom is what they sought,
and if you asked a dying patriot, he'll tell
you that they fought-
For random screenings at the airport with the
TSA all grabby,
while we place our toiletries out in transparent
plastic baggies,
and if you ask them why they fought and died
they'd give you the same answer:
so you can get pics taken of your junk while
slowly getting cancer.
Ask any single one of them it won't be no
surprise,
that's why they fought and died.
Well they braved the cold at Valley Forge
facing sacrifice and pain.
Yeah there was typhoid, measles, dysentery,
plus being in Pennsylvania.
But they went to fight the British to save
this independent nation
and with their final words they say they'd
died so our taxation-
could be on property and income with withholding
of our wages,
with this silly complex tax code over sixteen
thousand pages
and if you asked them why they gave their
lives they'd say they're only wish is
so you can fill out seven forms to prove that
pencil was for business.
Ask any single one of them, it won't be no
surprise,
That's why they fought and died.
Well they gave their lives-
So we could save up for a mortgage, woo!
They stormed that sandy beach-
So we could pay our neighbor's too.
They fought and died in fields with pride
and gave us all we hoped for-
to save us all from tyranny
and also from Four Loco.
Ask any single one of them, it won't be no
surprise,
that's why they fought and died.
That's why they fought and died.
That's why they gave their lives.
That's how you play it, blue.